[Music]
and back in my day news spare car
goodbye hi from Japan
teenagers have stopped getting summer
jobs I bet a little bit or strategic
fabric jar let me think about it then I
have a summer job no I have a summer job
I did I went to the Career Center in
high school and I said I need to get a
job and they say you need to get your
parents signature and I said [ __ ] that
so you started selling drugs yeah I
didn't have a summer job my was I didn't
have a summer job and I purposely didn't
go to school I'm like I am going to take
this [ __ ] time off I have to grind it
out you got you all worked before your
aunt day I had to work in my parents
door since I was 2 years old so I shadow
your precious child slavery like outside
of the normal one I know what I did need
help at the business I clean have a job
if I wanted to well I do wait let me let
me guess you worked at a barber shop I
did how did I know who are such a farmer
you you I feel like you are a typical
Asian girl ha ha ha ha
and at 6 to 6 they grow up they do they
do some type of athletic running or
tennis or ping-pong or something like
that they play inks but it's very good
big thing it's really great but I
remember I gotta go instrument and play
an instrument and I got decent grades
well you got good grades and then like
you work out like a Bulba shop the
station there is a real store oh my god
I wanted to work here so bad me too
nothing like that mm-hmm bye losers Alex
Evan and I was it like working out above
a shop it was cool um it was I think
well this boat was shop I thought it was
a bit different from most because it was
Japanese bass first was my training face
yeah look at Jeffrey Purcell builder
they stole the idea from the Chinese
well like um it's the company that also
makes like mochi ice cream and the green
tea ice cream like the best one
during the market that I still believe
today is colleague my 2n and they had
their like own little like branch but
I'm pretty sure they close their
branches like boba shops because they
couldn't like compete but it was really
good and the reason why I decided to
have like a summer job or even a
part-time job in high school is I knew
that like my family because I knew that
my family was having a little bit of
trouble financially so I was trying to
sell a telescoping oh now you let people
talk okay
she's coming on our story about she had
to work for a photo shop because her
parents needed money and she could pitch
in and you guys are not giving her wrist
rest she had it like a rubber band and I
guess he already got bored
we got the revenge for the rude one I
just saw aftermath that is due any day
then he put it on I'm not I'm not as
Noble as you as you uh painted me but
like I took a part-time job because I
didn't really want to spend my parents
money so I wanted to spend my own money
like on things I wanted to do that's
Noble she did see it Julia that was a
beautiful thing I didn't I didn't me but
I heard it and I saw the aftermath of
the rubber band right in front I said
Joe going that's the question I saw the
Crimea
the Bureau of Labor Statistics has said
that the number of teams with summer
jobs has decreased dramatically lazy ass
[ __ ] there's multiple reasons why
teens on how they were jobs anymore so
they're saying back in 1978 about sixty
percent of teens in the US were employed
in summer months that's a lot 60% the
more than half yeah and then now in 2016
when was that for years nineteen
seventy-eight specimen ass [ __ ] right so
some time out there do you have internet
or nothing to do at home and people go
faster I move on it was hilarious um I'm
sorry you can see the whole thing Joel I
know I'm missing even if I like it
[ __ ] cut smack the floor naked in it
baby red on the floor house but anyway
so they're saying last year only thirty
five percent of teens have how many 3500
[ __ ] yeah so teams aren't working
anymore and so so what do they think
Millennia's these days are lazy yeah org
is it the stores or the establishments
making it hard for them to be hired so
there's three main reasons number one
you're youtubers number one is that kids
these days are now staying in school
more often I go to drama school yeah so
they're staying in high school longer
they're taking summer classes and
they're going to college more than
before
intro oh that's right in the seventies
like they don't have that many people go
into the college like now that they have
a lot of people call college yeah
so they're saying that now a school is
teens summer jobs and they're also
mentioning that 16 to 19 year olds in
summer school has tripled in the last 20
years so that's why you're not getting
jobs is the first reason
second reason is that employers are more
reluctant to hire so the rise of
low-skilled immigrants coming into the
country have been they've pretty much
been taking the job
the team's like you know the easy jobs
like grocery store clerks wait yep those
are supposed to be teens jobs yes oh no
no there's low-skilled immigrants come
no fast-food work or the that supposed
to be like an entry-level experience to
the world type of jobs for teens but
they're testing like jobs those
immigrants yeah and so they're also
saying that older Americans are staying
in the workforce longer so then there
aren't that many jobs for teams to take
during the summer because adults are
just being and working longer and I just
stopped working like retire early
just give the young people a chance you
[ __ ] greedy [ __ ] is so funny it was
like white people keep the sector jobs
now I can't look back our jobs [ __ ]
old people cheers and they're also
saying that the number of federally
funded summer jobs have declined
federally funded like like a rec center
person or like that but in life car for
the summer cool exactly yeah a lot of
those jobs decline and that meant and
the fact that minimum wage has grown
it's making teens with no experience way
less likely to be hired yep because I
want to hire no [ __ ] dumb ass that
never had a job before and then like
[ __ ] that dude [ __ ] that could be
somebody else's problem and not only
that but now employers are more inclined
it's taking like unpaid internship feels
like with with these teams and so Sam
sees unpaid internships don't show up in
employment statistics we don't really
know like how many teams are really
working so their baseball a lot of them
might be getting job experience but not
actually getting paid yeah it's a little
bit better because don't go for the
chump change guys take your time and go
for the big goals or just so good that's
good - it seemed like the teens are
getting lazier yeah it just seems like
that's just the way like the entire
system is going so there's just less
pain getting jobs and it's not like
they're being lazy or they're being
preoccupied with social media or
wherever like I feel like a lot of the
parents that read stuff like this I know
my dad if you've read this it's always
do
bring my god next generation is [ __ ]
lazy as [ __ ] but it's actually it's not
it's just the way everything is going
people are preoccupied with other things
that are just as productive it seems
like I feel like teens now are a lot
[ __ ] smarter than even could we are
we internet they know to and they're
just like why the [ __ ] would I spend
time working for like chump change when
I can be spending time studying and then
when I'm out of high school or college
or whatever I could get a better job
the third main reason is the fact that
our culture has just changed a lot
especially with teens teens tend to do
what their peers are doing and
especially like they try to see like
what are the older kids up to and since
now older kids are looking into getting
jobs and internships that's what teams
are trying to do to during the summer I
wasn't even thinking of doing
internships and felt like college
yeah like teen as a teen I just wanted
to work at the grocery store because
they had Union now I remember when I was
in high school is getting more more
popular to like spend your summer going
to Community College and getting college
credits and trying to advance on this
point I feel like as a parent I have
certain little aspirations for my kids
just don't want him to die you know I
was like hey were you doing just don't
die I'm not doing bad I try to stress
out about the [ __ ] that you're doing if
you end up being homeless bro I did my
best as a parent I provided you food I
did how happy what you were doing yo you
told me that things were fine if things
aren't fine you lied to me that's your
fault
deal with it lazy ass sense no I'm doing
the food the food is not another fini I
know and love guidance
I can't even guide myself then you
should not be dedicated I think you'll
have a mother
so she'll help out a lot you know
there's kind of a double-edged sword to
the story though we're like yeah a lot
of the teens they're looking for like
the immediate career job coming right
out of college now but because what I've
noticed is the ones that haven't had the
more I guess tedious type of work
working at a grocery store or gas
station or like just having a job job
when they leave college they have the
intellect to hold
the career but they don't have to work
ethic yeah you know they have these
unrealistic expectations so now they
come straight out of college thinking
okay I'm going to land the big account
the big money of the career but they're
complaining like a little [ __ ] over the
first small thing that they don't like
versus if you do work out like a gas
station and you're supposed to be an
attendant sometimes it's why they
overfill so you got to you know work
outside of your job description or
sometimes someone knocks something over
you gotta go clean that up and there's a
lot of other things a lot of skill sets
that are actually built through these
menial jobs that they kind of lose out
on yeah I think for a period of time I
got pushes my sister because I was
working at Starbucks in college and she
was like oh what do you think about me
working out like a Jamba Juice or
something I'm like yeah I just do it if
you need the money and she's like I said
I can land something better than that
I'm like what would be better because
like of her education title yeah like
you know if you need money then go do
whatever it takes to get that money but
don't feel like you need to earn a
certain position in order to make that
she went to work at a horse Julia's old
actually does Bob I did do they still
exist a whole big on rolling that [ __ ]
back on Julius all in those potato
wedges that they had yeah hey guys I
hope you enjoyed that episode of just
kidding news and if there's a story that
you guys want us to talk about go ahead
down into our description box below and
there's a link there where you can
submit articles for the next video click
right up here
[Music]